if you drive down a certain stretch of
highway in the California desert you
will hear music it's supposed to sound a
little bit like this
[Music]
but instead it sounds like this
that was the musical road of Lancaster
California and as you may have heard
it's a little bit out of tune a lot of
money was spent on that road it was a
publicity stunt for a car company who
wanted to show off how clever they are
and doing the calculations for something
like that isn't really difficult a
musical note is a vibration in the air
at a particular frequency and those
vibrations can be made by a violin
string or synthesized by a computer or
in this case made by vehicle tires
hitting grooves in the road the closer
the grooves are the faster the
vibrations and the higher the note so
take the speed limit divided by the
frequency of the note you want and
that's how often there should be a
groove in the road and if people travel
at the wrong speed well it shouldn't
really matter if just be like slowing
down or speeding up any other bit of
music it'll be in the wrong key but
it'll still sound right to most people's
ears won't sound like that mess so what
went wrong at this point I'm indebted to
David Simmons Duffin an assistant
professor of physics at Caltech whose
interests include quantum field theories
and playing Baroque violin because he
was as far as I can tell the very first
person to figure out what went wrong and
the problem was probably the English
language whoever did the calculations
said that the grooves should be so far
apart let's say four inches for the
first note and they meant that there
should be a groove every four inches but
whoever gave the instructions to the
work crew said that the grooves should
be four inches apart and that was
interpreted as four inches between the
end of one groove and the start of the
next one they didn't include the width
of the groove itself but your ears
definitely do include it the highest
note on that section of the William Tell
Overture should be one octave higher
than the lowest that means the frequency
should be doubled and that the grooves
should be half the distance apart and
they are if you don't include the width
of the groove itself that error means
that every note is distorted not by a
fraction of its value like if you're
traveling at the wrong speed but by a
constant amount by the width of the
grooves the higher the note the greater
the effect of that distortion and the
result is the mess that you are about to
hear for a second time and the really
strange part this is the second musical
road built in Lancaster California the
first one built by the car company was
too close to residents who complained
about the constant noise and probably
this note here so the city paved over it
and rebuilt it to the exact same wrong
blueprints that's a take that is a tape
right there in order to celebrate that
take I'm going to put my foot down
[Music]
this is an SUV it doesn't it doesn't do
that